le plus méchant c'est qu'on m'a menacé
avec des avec les fusils ouverts comme
ça en menaçant dessus de te faire des
chiens
il y a plus de 2 millions et demi de
chasseurs en France c'est en ce moment
que l'on peut vraiment se rendre compte
puisque la période de chasse bas son
plein c'est l'occasion d'affrontement
parfois violent entre partisans et des
tracteurs de la chasse un sondage de
notre confrère le pèlerin nous indique
d'ailleurs que 16 % des Français sont
résolument contre et 57% disent oui à la
chasse mais en la limitant plus
strictement c'est vrai que les chasseurs
occupent beaucoup le territoire et qui
est devenu bien difficile en certains
endroits de se promener sans risque les
exemples d'accidents sont d'ailleurs
nombreux ce sont autant de raisons qui
nous ont incités à vous présenter à
partir de ce soir une série de
reportages sur les abus en matière de
chasse à la Valentini s'est promener un
petit peu partout en France et les
propos qu'il a arcueilli sont édifiants
soyons logiques soyons logiques soyons
logiques quand vous avez des des
chasseurs dans un bois et puis des
promeneurs ça peut pas faire bon ménage
parce que
[Musique]
vous promenez régulièrement les chiens
ici chaque dimanche à peu près chaque
dimanche chaque samedi après-midi mais
on est obligé de venir ici parce que
juste à côté de chez nous nous avons une
autre forêt où
j'ai évolue des chasseurs à longueur de
samedi ou de dimanche et qui nous
empêche évidemment de nous promener le
risque évidemment c'est que ma femme se
trouvait déjà interpellé plusieurs fois
et que bon bah on lui conseille
gentiment d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'on
vous a dit exactement
le plus méchant c'est qu'on va menacé
avec des avec les fusils ouverts comme
ça en menaçant de tuer un des chiens
comme nous l'a dit d'ailleurs
un chasseur que l'on a rencontré
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit oh bah il nous
a dit bon ben vous vous promenez dans
forêt bien sûr vous avez le droit on
peut pas on ne peut pas vous interdire
mais si vous êtes blessé nous on répond
rien on a une carte de chasse donc on
est autorisé à le faire alors c'est
presque du meurtre autorisé
[Musique]
un peu plus balader en forêt quoi enfin
à chaque fois on se virer en disant en
fait attention c'est normal c'est un peu
logique moi si je me promène en forêt je
peux il y a des parcs régionaux il y a
des parcs régionaux qui sont la chasse
est interdite par rapport à ça
parce que maintenant elle est réservée
en parc national et que pour les
promeneurs et nous on sait tous les
soirs
c'est pas gratuit vous voyez un endroit
pour un pas parce que vous payez qu'il
faut virer les autres
vous pouvez payer pour aller vous
promener aussi
vous payez un si vous payez un droit
pour pour chasser c'est votre droit mais
c'est aussi quand même le droit à mon
droit d'aller me promener tranquillement
dans un bois pour chasser où on a le
droit de chasser ou vous allez payer à
droite vous vous promener vous allez
droit vous prendre non vous pouvez payer
vous pouvez payer pour chasser mais en
laissant les gens se promener dans le
bois
soyez logique soyez logique
non mais soyez logique lorsque vous avez
un fusil dans les mains c'est pas un
yoyo
pour aller jouer c'est exact bon bah si
vous avez des promeneurs et vous le
savez pas il y a quelque chose qui perd
vous êtes vous croyez vraiment être tout
seul vous donnez un coup de fusil
qu'est-ce qui est à vous de faire
attention
avec vous mais soyons logiques soyons
logiques soyons logiques quand vous avez
des des des chasseurs dans un bois et
puis des promeneurs et ben ça peut pas
faire bon ménage
et quand on habite un petit pavillon
lisière d'un bois au long chasse la
situation pour la famille n'est pas
encourageante
et bien un après-midi de chasse on a
entendu un bruit sur les tuiles qui
était apparemment des plombs qui
retombaient après avoir entendu un tas
de coup de feu dans la dans le bois quoi
vraiment près de la maison
mais il y a souvent des enfants qui
jouissent ici donc les miennes qui sont
assez petites et qui jouent très souvent
sur la terrasse ou même qui vont se
promener dans le terrain enfin le fait
qu'il y ait des plombs sur le toit ça
prouve tout de même que on peut tirer un
coup de feu assez près
la maison est visible
quand on n'a pas demandé à vivre
dangereusement il faut bien reconnaître
que de tels agressions sont
inadmissibles ce n'est pas autre chose
qu'une atteinte à la liberté d'aller et
de venir à laquelle nous avons tous
droit c'est sur l'élevage du gibier que
nous reviendrons demain un gibier qui
n'emporte d'ailleurs plus que le nom
[Musique]